intolerant attitude very good put that
down Britton schools are learning a
demanding new subject countering
extremism these safeguarding my eyes
that I need to be talked about discussed
are quite important for the welfare of
the children the community and the
school as a whole this school in
Bradford has embraced the now compulsory
prevent strategy but not without
modifying it first our students would
have been taken back by them just kind
of dictating to them and telling them
what they are
unfortunately responsible for however
what we do we actually change that
program and adapted it to our own
students so it was kind of a a global
message but in a local level for this
mother prevent doesn't just have the
potential to demonize Muslims it's
already a reality if that's 14 year old
son was interrogated alone after
mentioning the phrase eco-terrorist
during a class discussion about the
rainforest I said all you affiliate to
Isis and I think that's when he was
really shook up and really scared he
felt he was really poor the school
community he's trusted teachers know him
he's responsible and then to be
interrogated in that manner I think it
was from absolutely shocking and it's
creating suspicions and my son NASA he's
doesn't he's not so vocal in his lessons
for fear that anything he says it's
gonna be misconstrued and that's no way
for a child to be growing up the number
of referrals under the government's
de-radicalization channel program has
increased dramatically in recent years
of the six thousand three hundred and
six individuals referred since 2007 a
quarter were made in the last year alone
including five hundred and seventy seven
children under the age of 18 the
youngest child referred was just four
years old the number of referrals from
within schools has also escalated from
just twenty in 2012 to four hundred and
twenty four last year it's exactly
places like this in new and East London
with its exceptional diversity that
Muslims say they feel particularly
singled out by the prevent strategy and
that's creating a deep sense of mistrust
which salma warning could have seriously
adverse consequences kalila hair is one
of a group of new Imams who this week
issued a public statement denouncing
prevent we don't need this current
prevent strategy with the Muslim
community we'll fill our suspects and
then feeling like suspects will lead to
them feeling victimized and this being
victimized will sideline the whole
community and this is one of the key
reasons which could lead to extremism
but for others the issue is not about
prevent itself but the need for better
training for those on the front line
there's there's a lot of
misunderstanding about the terminology
and there's a lot of assumptions made
the message is very clear that this is
not a counterterrorism strategy and
targeting the Muslim community good
anybody else yes Issa there's no doubt
that a minority of children within the
Muslim community are vulnerable to
radicalization the challenge is how to
reach them without making the problem
worse have four Hersh Sky News